[Music]
so time for the press preview it's our
first look at the front pages and
tonight we'll be checking out the
headlines with the columnist carol
malone and the political editor of the
liverpool echo liam thought they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight very good evening to you both
looking as if you're keeping cool we'll
chat in a moment first of all let's have
a look at some of those front pages for
you starting with the i reporting that
the drought conditions affecting the
country may be here to stay for months
to come
well the guardian says ministers are
considering even tougher restrictions
than hosepipe bans to tackle the water
crisis
the express goes with what it calls
shock news of the latest prediction that
energy bills could soon hit 5 000 pounds
a year
pm turns up for meeting is the slightly
sarcastic tone taken by the metro after
boris johnson met energy bosses at
downing street to discuss the spiraling
cost of bills however as it points out
no new action has been taken
the mirror pictures some of those
present at the meeting and calls them
clueless
meanwhile the telegraph leads with a
promise from liz trust that there will
be no windfall tax on energy companies
if she becomes the new prime minister
while the times goes with rishi sunax
plan to cancel out energy price rises by
spending up to 10 billion pounds
the ft leads with a warning from the
bank of england to the tory leadership
candidates not to interfere with the way
the city of london is regulated for fear
of damaging the country's
competitiveness
and the star looks at the way all the
problems the country is facing at the
moment are being dealt with and asks
crisis
what crisis while the sun has the latest
from that trial of former footballer
ryan giggs
and don't forget you can scan the qr
code that you can see on screen
throughout the programme check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch us at discussing them and
we're joined now by carol and liam uh
great to see you both this evening um
looking remarkably chilled which is good
to see uh it's getting hotter carol
isn't it the front of the guardians got
this remarkable picture really worrying
actually one of the uh the wildfires uh
that took place today this one in
leytonston in east london
um
i mean it's it's a real concern now
temperatures rising yet again and uh
tomorrow we're expecting these drought
announcements
yeah
yeah that's going to be announced
tomorrow and that basically means that
the water companies can impose very
tough restrictions on us now and when
they they when they impose them they
don't have to seek permission from the
government to impose them now you know
scientists are saying that it's highly
unlikely that they're going to be as
tough as the measures in 76 where we had
stand pipes in the streets and water was
rushing they're saying it's not going to
be as severe as that however they are
going to be tough on people and this is
kind of enrages me a bit you know when
you when you understand that all these
water companies that make vast profits
they let it every day they're letting a
third to a quarter of all the water they
supply to us they're letting it run away
with leaks you know every year we keep
hearing that they're gonna they're gonna
fix their infrastructure they're gonna
fix the leaks they're gonna sort it out
and they never do they just divide the
profits up and that's that has got to
stop there's got to be some tough action
taken and i don't quite know what that
action should be the government should
either force them to fix the leaking
pipes because if they did we wouldn't be
going into a drought situation tomorrow
we'd have enough water so we either
force them to fix the infrastructure or
we temporarily nationalize it you know
this is a this is a this belongs to the
public water belongs to the public it's
a utility and if we're short of it if
we're going to be sure that it isn't
just the fact we haven't had much
rainfall for the past nine months
although that is severe we wouldn't be
going into these restrictions if the
water companies weren't losing all of
this water and that is effect and and so
if we have to temporarily nationalize
the the water well then so be it because
we can't have this every couple of years
and that's what we've seen over the last
decade yeah echoing uh what gordon brown
was saying today about energy companies
perhaps temporarily renationalizing them
as well liam how how's the situation in
your part of the country
it's very hot first of all i just want
to say i didn't i did not expect to come
on tonight and immediately hear carol uh
advocating nationalization um which i i
don't know
no i know i know i don't usually agree
with it
i think that shows the scale of the
situation we're facing both in terms of
the water issue and and yeah the energy
companies as well um it's very hot here
obviously northern england a little bit
cooler than than in parts of the
southeast but we're still up at we're
still up at sort of 32 degrees in parts
today and it's going to get hotter again
and i think what we're seeing across the
country in various forms is that our
infrastructure our services you know
they're just not up to this they're just
not ready for it that you've got the
warning from the fire brigades union
today saying that because of the the
cuts that they've faced over the last 10
years they are completely
unprepared to deal with these tinderbox
conditions that are going to be created
you see that picture on the front of the
the guardian that's one of a number of
wildfires that have already happened and
that's before temperatures go to around
36 37 we saw in the the more recent heat
wave many large scale fires coming and
unfortunately we are just not equipped
to deal with this i saw a few comments
from people at that point saying you
know that people
that this happens in europe more
regularly well first of all it's
happening to devastating effect in
france right now a monstrous uh
three-day wildfire going on in france
but also in in europe people are
generally more well equipped to deal
with these things as well in terms of
air conditioning and some of the
services they used to the uk is not
ready for this at all and it is a real
worry
yeah and carol the front of the eye um
saying uh the heatwave uh uh the drought
could last for for months it's been
declared in several regions uh in
england but there are concerns that it's
not going to be over any time soon
i have i have to tell you jonathan i
don't i mean i was looking for evidence
of that claim um inside the paper and i
can't find it you know i mean i think we
don't know what the weather's going to
be like in two and a half weeks time so
we can't actually know that this is
going to last for months so i don't
think we're going to have a heat wave
into october um i mean i just think
that's you know i i'm a bit i get a bit
cross with the media at times like this
because you know
we ramp up things to a point where we're
terrifying people we can't possibly know
that this heat wave is going to last for
months this is just to me this is
headline making um you know if i were
talking not are we talking into november
we're going to have a heat wave in
november it's silly of course we're not
so you know i just i just think you know
we're in a time of crisis and i get a
bit crossed with my own industry
sometimes where you know where we're
taking a bad situation and we're making
it 150 times worse in people's head you
know we're terrifying people today both
with this and with with the cost of
living crisis yeah
you make a very valid point well let's
talk about the cost of living crisis uh
shall we liam front of the metro uh pm
turns up for meeting uh a rather
sarcastic headline there boris johnson
meeting energy bosses today not that it
did much good
no absolutely not i mean it's a great
headline from the metro it just it just
says it in plain facts just what a
ridiculous situation we're in i saw
someone on twitter today saying only
boris johnson could make a surprise
appearance at a crisis meeting you know
they did they weren't expecting the
prime minister to be there which which
is a remarkable circumstance really yes
of course it's a slightly unusual
situation in the in the sense that we
know he's going but he said when he when
he announced he was resigning that he
would continue to carry out his duties
he would you know be there for the
british people now i didn't particularly
believe him at the time but he said it
and he's been completely awol sort of
d-mob happy he's been off running around
having parties and and pretending to be
in the army and things like that while
we are facing up to a generational cost
of living crisis that
certainly people of my age have never
seen the like before and many people
have not seen and huge numbers of people
are going to suffer and every day that
passes as gordon brown has said every
single day that passes will make it
harder to to put the mechanisms in place
that will be necessary to keep people
from falling into abject poverty so for
for boris johnson to just casually turn
up today have a little chat and then
announce absolutely nothing has has
helped absolutely no one in this
situation and it's deeply frustrating
things need to be put in place right now
regardless of the situation with the
prime minister carol is that a fair
criticism it's a similar theme on the
front of the mirror i don't think it's a
fake criticism i mean i think liam's
absolutely right measures need to be put
in place now but boris johnson can't do
that lehman you know it he can't make
any sweeping changes right now because
they will be blown away by whoever takes
his job you know that that will be part
of the deal but
what i totally agree with what you say
is that you know i mean after that that
meeting today was a farce you have all
those energy fat cats coming all these
guys who are nearly a million and women
who were on nearly a million quid a year
and they cut they come out of there and
and when they've gone they said we're
all going to work together well we we'd
presume that and it says that they're
gonna some you know they were asked to
submit their profits and how they're
broken down well the government should
already know that they shouldn't be
going into the meeting today and asking
that question nahim desires i can't say
him just i can't
he said that you know they're still
evaluating the obscene profits that some
of these companies make well why are you
still evaluating them i know what
profits they're making so why doesn't
the government we all know in the
country what profits they're making
because they've been printed so why
aren't they doing something about it
this to me is just this is a government
that is not there and and
and it's a government that i want to
support but i can't because they're just
not there and it's not just because
they're on holiday it's because no one's
actually got a plan you know by the time
the cold weather comes in october by the
time they get round to putting it
planned together the elderly are going
to be freezing to death in their homes i
mean do people have to die first before
they put a planet i did it i did a
program this week a show and i i we had
a phone in and there were pensioners on
the phone saying i mean these these
people have made me weep they were
terrified some of these people have 250
quid a week to pay everything and
they're reading all these terrible
stories about energy doubling sometimes
tripling in prices and they are
desperate and it broke my heart and here
we have this government faffing around
and saying oh you know we'll get where
you know
there's plans of footwear you are
working together well work harder
frankly because you haven't got time
okay we're going to go to the break i
know you're reaching to come back liam
but we'll we'll speak more on this uh in
a couple of minutes uh also uh
discussing uh liz trust because she's
outlining one of the ways that she won't
be tackling the energy price quite since
don't go
[Music]
hello again part two of the press
preview carol and liam still with me
let's look at the front of the daily
telegraph uh liam as we were saying
before the break boris johnson uh making
it clear it's up to his successor to to
really come up with solutions for the
cost of living crisis well one of them
liz truss or one of the candidates to
become his successor has said there'll
be no increase in the windfall tax on
energy companies she says it's a labor
idea what do you make of this
it's it's i find it extraordinary and
pretty terrifying that this is the
person that is the favorite to be the
prime minister that will you know take
us through this crisis and her
priorities are are completely all over
the place obviously she is appealing to
a particular selector and we know those
those story members will be wealthier
and in more comfortable positions but
you know if she wins she's going to be a
prime minister for the whole country
including the millions of people that
are about to be pushed into fuel poverty
into general poverty and one very
obvious way to to to raise money is on
the huge profits being created by these
energy companies and i think she's got
this badly badly wrong i think even you
know we're seeing middle-income
households worrying about how on earth
they're going to pay their bills we
obviously know that people on the lowest
incomes pensioners who physically cannot
increase their income and and then
they're seeing this potential rise of as
much as 5 000 pounds your energy bills
next year so for her to be sort of
backing the energy companies in this way
you know she says in these quotes about
how profit shouldn't be a dirty word and
that it sends out the wrong word to
international investors i find it
absolutely staggering when people are
you know so many people are going to be
worried about whether they can actually
put food on the table heat their homes
that she's she's backing international
investors and
you know energy fat cats in this in this
race i think it's going to come back to
honor to be honest because i think it's
real misjudgment yeah carol you you're
nodding away and i just wanted to to to
slide in the times very quickly because
rishi sunax taken a real swipe at liz
truss in the time saying that you can't
heat your home with hope uh he's come up
with plans which he's described to the
to the times for uh 10 billion pounds to
help software up to 10 billion pounds
help soften the impact of the of the
price rise we're expecting in october
i mean this is a this is right you know
i i agree with living on two points i'm
terrified that liz trust is going to get
the job as running this country and two
she has a 10 year where this is concert
you know she knows she must surely know
what the british people feel about the
profits uh that these energy companies
are making as they face you know
devastation this winter for her to come
back she said the other day she didn't
want to give families real help
struggling families actual help because
she didn't want to give them handouts
well they need handouts now when their
bills are going to double or triple so
but she makes that sound like oh i'm not
going to insult them by giving them
handover and then she says here profits
are not a dirty word well they are if
these people oh you know there was one
story today where there just a lot of
these energy companies are trying to fix
these very high bills for people they
are they are profiting from people's
fear so they're saying we're going to
double your cap but you can fix it for
that for the next year and a half so
that if it goes up again it's not going
to hurt you i mean this is profiteering
on the backs of terrified people and
enlist trust siding with those people
and i can't belie soon i could play the
blind on this one this is absolutely the
right thing to do what he's saying is it
would basically pay all of the bills for
16 million of the most vulnerable people
and that's what the british people want
to hear at this moment not someone
sticking up for people who are making
obscene profits um liam final thought
from you on this just reading that
article in the telegraph she does talk
about um fracking doesn't she she says
we need to make sure we're fracking
parts of the country where there is
local support for it i mean is that one
solution
no absolutely ludicrous even if it was a
solution and it's not been proven to to
bring our energy costs down at all it
certainly won't be helping people this
winter you know there's a moratorium on
fracking at the moment it would take a a
fair amount of time for that to even
happen we know there are environment
serious environmental concerns it's an
another pie in the sky idea from liz
trust to appeal to a certain selectorate
it will do absolutely nothing to help
people who in a matter of weeks are
going to be facing the most testing and
difficult times of their lives she's
completely and utterly out of touch yeah
okay thank you both very much